My name is Vin, and I've been teaching
communication skills now for the last 15
years to CEOs, Fortune 500 companies,
and millions of people from all over the
world. And in that time, there are
things I used to believe deeply about
communication that I also taught
confidently from the stage, and I was
wrong. Yeah, I was wrong on those
things. So, here are the five big things
I got wrong about communication, and
this is what I now believe instead. And
I need to share this with you because
there's a real chance you believe some
of the same things that I used teach.
And if you keep believing them, it'll
actually make you a worse communicator,
not a better one. Number one, fake it
till you make it. I used to teach this
idea with a lot of conviction. Act as if
you're a confident person. If you're not
a confident person yet, just pretend,
and eventually you'll become confident.
I said that for years because on the
surface it made sense. But the older
that I got, the more I started to
realize that I sent people in the wrong
direction. Because when you tell
yourself you're faking it, then there's
this part of you that knows you're
faking it. And if it's something you can
feel, then trust me, other people can
feel it as well. When I was in my early
20s, I did a few months of work
experience at a large accounting firm.
And I remember walking in every single
day thinking I had to become this
version of myself that looked more
professional, more polished, and more
corporate. I spoke louder and used
larger gestures. I dressed in a suit and
tie. I was constantly pretending to be
that person because again, in my mind, I
was faking it until I was going to make
it. Then I made the same mistake again
in a completely different part of my
life. For years, I wanted to improve my
fashion sense because my wardrobe was
very simple. White t-shirts, black
t-shirts, baggy pants, that was it. Kind
of feels like I'm describing one of my
coworkers, Peter, over there. Seriously,
Peter, change it up. There came a point
where I wanted to change things up a
bit, but I brought the same mindset, the
fake it till you make it one. I tried
wearing tight blue jeans, and then
immediately felt, "Ew, you're being
fake. You're being phony."
But over time I started to realize that
me trying on new different types of
clothes, it doesn't make me inauthentic,
it doesn't make me fake, it doesn't make
me phony. It was just me exploring my
fashion sense. That was it. Just trying
it on. If I don't like it, it doesn't
mean I have to keep it on. I'm just
exploring, and the clue there is the
word explore.
So, instead of continuing with that
mindset and thinking to myself, "Fake it
till you make it." I started thinking,
"You know what? This is just me
exploring the unfamiliar, trying on
things I've never tried before." This
not only applied to the way that I
explored my fashion sense, it applied to
the way I approached my communication
skills journey. As I started to speak
louder, because I wanted to be more
confident, I didn't feel fake anymore.
And the reason I didn't feel fake is
because to me, the mindset shift had
been made. I'm now just exploring the
unfamiliar. I'm just exploring the
unfamiliar volumes that I used to never
play with. And as I started to use
bigger body language, again, I didn't
feel fake. It was just me exploring the
unfamiliar. And that language pattern
makes all the difference, because one
path feels like you're acting, while the
other path feels like discovery. And if
you want to begin your own exploration
process of your own communication
skills, you need to first develop
self-awareness.
What are you doing wrong with your
voice? What are you doing wrong with
your body language? What are you doing
wrong with the structure of how you
speak? Without self-awareness, you can't
improve the way you communicate. So,
I've created a three-part program that's
going to help you do so, and you can
access it for completely free. Well, I'm
going to walk you through exactly how to
identify the non-functional
communication habits that you exhibit on
a daily basis. And if you want to access
this free training, just scan the QR
code or click the link in the
description below. Millions of people
have been through this, and it's
dramatically shifted the way they
communicate almost immediately. Okay,
now to false belief number two,
communication is a performance. For a
long time, I believed that masterful
communication was just a performance,
and that belief came from a very
specific part of my life. Here's where
it started. I used to be a professional
magician in my early 20s, and during
that time, I lived by this powerful
quote by a magician named Jean Eugene
Robert-Houdin, and he said, "A magician
is just an actor
>> [music]
>> playing the part
of a magician." When I read that quote,
I understood that if I wanted to become
a better magician, I needed to learn how
to perform and act. So, I went and
started theater classes. I studied
performance, vocal pace, gestures, stage
presence, how to command a room. I
eventually became a better performer,
but here's where I went wrong. Without
realizing it, I took those lessons from
the world of theater, and I applied it
to real-world communication. I started
to perform in every single conversation,
every single presentation. On the
surface, I was doing everything right.
The skills were there, the technique was
there, but the intent was completely
wrong. I wasn't communicating to connect
with people. I was communicating to
impress them. Again, I learned this from
the world of theater because in the
world of theater, you're performing to
impress often and most of the time. And
that's what happens when you get stuck
in that performance mode. Your focus is
on how you come across, not how to
connect with the person in front of you.
So, let me give you something practical
you can take away from this. The next
time you walk into a conversation,
whether it's in a meeting, a
presentation, or a first date, whatever
the situation, pay attention to the
questions running in the back of your
mind. Because in performance mode, the
questions you're asking yourself
constantly are, "How am I coming across
right now? Am I sounding smart enough?
Am I saying the right thing? Do they
think I'm credible? Are they impressed
with me?" You see the problem with these
questions? They're all about you. It's
just me, me, me, me, me. But when you
switch to connection mode, the questions
that you're thinking in the back of your
head, they should change. What are they
actually feeling? [music]
What are they not saying in our
conversation right now? What would make
them feel like I actually see them? See
the difference with these questions?
They put the focus on the other person.
And let me be really clear with you,
too. The first time I made this
conscious switch, it felt a little bit
uncomfortable because when you stop
performing, you have to get rid of the
scripts that [music] you've been
repeating for the longest time. You
don't know what you want to say next now
because you're actually listening to the
person waiting for your turn to speak.
And trust me, the person that's sitting
in front of you, they can feel the
difference between you trying to be
impressive and you trying to sit there
and understand them. They might not
immediately be able to label it, but
trust me, again, they can feel it. Now
to number three. This one I'm actually a
little bit embarrassed about to be
honest because I spent years teaching
people how to speak better and almost no
time teaching them how to listen better.
Yeah. Back in 2016, I ran my first
communication skills class in America.
It was actually in a theater in Long
Beach, Southern California. We had a
theater with 200 seats and about 35
people showed up. And I ran a three-day
workshop on voice training, body
language, storytelling, presence, all of
it. And near the end of day three, with
about 1 hour left, there was a woman
named Mary. She She raised her hand and
she said, "Hey Vin, there's only 1 hour
left. When are we going to learn about
active listening? Are you taking us
through listening?"
And I replied back to her and I said,
"Mary, this is a class on public
speaking, not not public listening."
>> [laughter]
>> And I thought people were going to
laugh. The very next day, Mary sent me
an email and she was giving me very
strong feedback and she told me that I'd
missed the larger half of communication
in my entire [music] workshop.
And you know what? Yep, she was right.
I'd spent my whole early 20s learning
how to be heard and I obsessed about it
to the point where I didn't realize I
was missing the other 50% of
communication. I never made others feel
heard. I never had active listening in
my repertoire. Let me show you an
example of what Vin was like before he
learned how to listen. And then I'm
going to show you another example of Vin
after he learned how to listen. Have a
look at this before and after. Vin, I
just started doing archery and man, it's
so difficult.
>> god, I love archery. It's so easy.
I just started doing archery and man,
it's so difficult. But the thing I love
most about it is how present it makes me
feel. Oh Peter, that sounds so
beautiful, man. I'm so glad that you
found a hobby that helps you relax and
unwind. Yeah, man. My work is so
stressful working with a boss who's just
like a massive tyrant and but ever since
I started doing archery, my quality of
life has improved massively. Man, I love
I love talking to you. Ah, it's all
good, Peter. It's my pleasure, man. Get
back to work.
Yeah, I think Peter forgets that I'm
actually his boss sometimes.
Before I learned how to listen, every
relationship in my life was pretty
surface level. And I used to wonder,
why? Why don't I have more depth in my
life? Why does every conversation feel
like small talk? And I freaking hated
small talk.
Why does everybody not want to go deeper
with me? I see them go deeper with other
people. And then I started to realize
that well, people did want to go deeper
with me. They were leaving clues in
every single conversation, little
openings, little moments where they were
inviting me into their lives, but I
missed all of them. Every single damn
time because I wasn't listening. I was
just waiting for my bloody turn to talk.
I need to hammer this point home. I'm
going to show you another skit, another
example because it's critical that you
get exactly what I mean here. Yo, Pete,
how was your night last night? Yeah, it
was okay, I guess.
>> Oh, that's good. I'm glad to hear that.
Okay, well, work is No, that works that
way. Work harder.
Attaboy. Did you notice that? Peter's
voice gave away that he was feeling a
little down. And the pause before he
said it was okay, the word choice saying
okay, I guess. These are all clues that
if I picked up on it, it could have led
to this instead. Yo, Pete, how was your
night last night? Yeah, it's been okay,
I guess.
Uh, doesn't sound okay, man. You want to
talk about it? Man, my work's just been
piling up. I've been working extra hours
and it's just I've just been having to
take my work home. It's just been so
overwhelming. Ah, Pete, you silly
bugger. All you got to do is take half
of your workload over here, take it from
this desk, move it over here, and give
it to old mate Andy. He's happy with
this, aren't you, Andy?
You see, we're all happy now. All of us,
a big old happy family, all ready to
work together. You got this, Pete. There
are opportunities for depth in every
single conversations that exist all
around you, all around me, all around
all of us. Most of us just don't listen.
We miss the vocal cues. We miss the
visual cues. As you start to listen
more, you'll start to deepen the
connection you feel with others and
others feel with you.
What I now believe is that listening is
just as important as speaking, if not
more important. So, Mary, thanks for
this lesson. You've actually made me a
better person. False belief number four,
the introvert and extrovert myth. I used
to believe that if you're an introvert,
it's fine for you to stay small, it's
fine for you to speak quietly. That's
just who you are. Don't worry about it.
And I wouldn't push my introverted
students as hard. And for as long as I
used to believe this, I was only serving
half of my class. I remember this
conversation I had with my vocal
teacher, Miss Stanley. She said, "Vin, I
want you to imagine two world-class
pianists. One is an introvert and the
other one is an extrovert. Does this
change how they play their instrument?
Between the extrovert and the introvert,
does it change how they play?" And what
I learned from Miss Stanley was that the
instrument does not care about your
personality type. And with just this one
lesson, Miss Stanley rewired the way I
think about this entire situation.
Because your voice and your body
language, your ability to connect with
another human being, that's your
instrument. Just like the piano, it
doesn't care whether you're an introvert
or an extrovert, it only cares whether
you're good with the instrument. I've
worked with thousands of students over
the last 15 years, and some of the most
magnetic communicators I've ever seen
are deeply introverted. They're not
loud, they're not the center of
attention all the time, but when they
need to be, when they speak, people lean
in because they've done the work.
They've learned how to use their
instrument. They can switch it on and
they can switch it off. So, to the
introverts watching this video, stop
using that as a label and as a reason
for you not to try and for you not to
learn how to use your voice and your
body language. You're not disqualified
from being a great communicator, you
just haven't given yourself permission
to practice because you've been using
this as an excuse. And to the
extroverts, don't assume that you're
sorted. Being comfortable talking is not
the same thing as being bloody good at
it. And here's where this goes even
deeper down the rabbit hole. Take a deep
breath. We're about to go down and see
how deep this rabbit hole actually goes.
For a long time, I thought the way that
I communicated just was who I was. This
is just my voice. This is just how I
sound. This is just me. I actually never
questioned it until I sat with this
idea. The way you communicate right now,
it's not something you were born with.
It's something that you absorbed
from your parents, your siblings, your
friends, your teachers, the other kids
at school. Every single person you were
around during your formative years left
a mark on the way you speak and the way
you listen and the way you carry
yourself. What you have right now is a
collection of habits that you've picked
up without even realizing it. And here's
why this is important. If it's a habit,
it can be changed. The version of you
that shows up in a conversation right
now, that's just one version of you.
It's not the final version of you, but
for as long as you keep telling
yourself, "This is how I am. This is how
I'm forever going to be." you're never
going to evolve into the future version
of you. So, here's what I want you to
take away from this. Your personality
type is not your ceiling. It's just your
starting point. An introvert who puts in
the work will outperform an extrovert
who doesn't every single time. And the
way you communicate today is not
permanent. It's just the familiar. It's
just a series of habits and habits you
can change. You've already proven to
yourself that you can change the way you
communicate. You speak differently when
you're with your best mate as compared
to when you speak with your boss. You
speak differently when you're with your
kids as opposed to when you're speaking
to a stranger. You already have range.
You just haven't made it conscious yet.
So, stop asking, "Am I an introvert or
am I an extrovert?" and allow that to
dictate how you communicate and start
asking these questions instead. Have I
actually practiced with my instrument?
Have I truly started to explore what
this instrument is capable of? Am I
still letting who I was back in the past
decide who I get to become in the
future? Because those are the only
questions that matter. Not am I
introvert or am I an extrovert. Point
number five, communication is a science.
For a long, long time, I treated
communication like it was a science.
Oxygen plus hydrogen makes water every
single time, no exceptions, fixed
inputs, fixed outputs, it's science,
man. That's how I thought about
communication skills. Louder voice,
bigger gestures, stronger contact equals
influence every single time. And then I
tried it in the real world and this is
really weird, but it worked in some
rooms and in others it made me come
across as intimidating, over the top and
a little bit too much. It was the same
inputs, but I had different outputs. I
remember thinking to myself, "What the
freak? This is weird." I had the same
experience with humor. I'd tell a story
that was light, warm, funny, and in one
room it hits perfectly. And then in
another room, the exact same story, the
exact same delivery, it offended
somebody. Same words, completely
different impact. That's when I realized
that communication isn't a science, it's
an art form. Science will give you fixed
rules. Art gives you principles. Art
requires you to read the context, feel
the room, and then adjust in real time.
You can't just run the formula, you have
to develop judgment. And this one belief
changed the way that I teach. Because
once I stopped treating communication
like a science, I stopped obsessing over
the perfect formula, and I started
paying attention to something that's
much more important, emotional
intelligence. And in about 82 seconds,
I'm going to give you a practical way to
learn and apply EQ, emotional
intelligence. Emotional intelligence is
not just a formula. You can't just
memorize the right amount of eye
contact, pair it with the right number
of gestures, and the right vocal tone,
and expect that combination to work in
the same way in every single room, with
every single person, in every single
situation. Life doesn't work like that.
And human beings definitely don't work
like that. What works beautifully for
one person can feel way too intense for
another. What feels playful and warm to
one can come across as disrespectful to
a different person in a different room.
What feels supportive to another person
can feel patronizing to someone else.
Even though you've said the exact same
things with the words, with the exact
same delivery. And that's exactly why
communication is an art form. Because
art requires that sensitivity, and an
artist doesn't just slap on paint all
over a canvas and hopes for the best.
They're constantly paying attention,
constantly adjusting, constantly
responding to what's in front of them.
And that's what emotional intelligent
communication looks like in practice.
It's the ability to read what's
happening in real time, and then adjust
how you show up based on what the moment
needs from you. It's knowing when to
bring the energy, when to bring the
softness. It's knowing when to bring a
joke that's going to help break the
tension, versus when the same joke is
going to make things worse. It's knowing
when to speak up and when the most
powerful thing you can do is just hold
space
and listen. Okay, so here's a practical
tip. If you want to get better at
emotional intelligence, stop walking
into conversations trying to be the most
impressive person in the room, referring
back to the rule before, and start
walking into the room with a different
question. What's this particular moment?
What's this moment asking of me? Not
what worked in the last room that I was
in or what's the best line for me to use
here, but really think about what does
this specific person in front of me,
what do they need right now? Do they
need encouragement? Do they need
certainty? Do they need me to slow down?
Do they need me to listen more? Or do
they need me to share some advice?
Because emotional intelligence is really
just the ability to notice what's
happening in the room in front of you.
What has changed in this moment? How do
I change with it? That is real-time
feedback. [music] Then the more you tune
into it, the better your judgment
becomes over time. So yes, learn the
skills, learn the frameworks, learn all
of the mechanics. Everything you're
learning matters, but never forget the
mechanics, that's not the art form. The
art is in how well you can feel what the
moment requires from you and respond to
it in real time. That is communication
and that is emotional intelligence
paired with masterful communication.
Those are the five things I got wrong
early in my communication skills
journey. And what I believe now has
completely changed the way I show up as
a person and [music] as a teacher in
this space. So make sure you leave a
like and subscribe because this helps
the YouTube algorithm send our videos to
more people like yourself. And if you
want to go deeper and explore your
communication skills and develop more
self-awareness, make sure you go and
check out my free three-part video
series in the description or you can
scan [music] the QR code up there. I'll
see you next video.